[Music]
why do I have an erection when I wake up
in the morning there is a natural rise
and fall of testosterone which peaks in
the early morning hours unrelated to the
content of your dream
this causes the erections you discover
when you wake up why does it hurt so
much that get hit in the balls there are
a lot of sensory nerves in and around
the genitalia the muscles in the scrotum
that served to pull the testicles up
into the pelvis for protection are not
big and thick like the muscles in your
thighs back or arms
if these scrotal muscles were that big
the heat generated with slow or stop
sperm production is not penis supposed
to curve to the side it is actually very
uncommon for a penis to be completely
straight most penises will curve to
either side though when erect usually
point north there is only an issue if
you experience pain during or after an
erection are my man boobs too big during
puberty in an early manhood males can
have enlarged glands under their nipples
this is called gynecomastia and usually
subsides you can also see enlargement
with marijuana use and with certain
medications if you're sporting a d-cup
you should probably get it investigated
wearing tight jeans reduce my sperm
count probably not wearing tight clothes
would only reduce your sperm count if it
were to raise the temperature around
your genitalia preventing the sperm from
occurring but ordinarily men are not
affected by this unless they are wearing
space-age heat [ __ ] underwear what do
you want to know about your body
[Music]
[Music]